well let's let's let's talk about that
we have the story from people
crosby stills nash and uh not neil young
i know crosby stills in ash music is
back on spotify months after joe rogan
boycott so the big story was that uh you
know joe rogan and this compilation went
viral and everyone was calling joe rogan
racist and all that he apologized for it
but uh all of these people were like i'm
taking my music off of spotify and uh
crosby still and nash as well as neil
young they did they're back that's it
they're back actually neil young i guess
half his music stayed on because he
didn't know it anyway that was actually
really funny but this is really
important it shows you the depth of
their of their values
none shallow not even an inch deep
they did this because it was major press
let me tell you guys
when i was uh doing the occupy wall
street stuff i had all of these
companies hitting me up being like we
want to give you all these things we
want to you know hire you and i'm like
yeah yeah yeah something happened in the
press
you want to put your press release and
be like this guy's with us now so you
can get free press off of somebody else
i'm not interested that's all they did
these guys were there they probably had
a manager who was like guys guys now's
your chance it's big in the news it's
joe rogan he's the biggest podcaster
come out say something we'll craft some
line for you we'll take your music down
for a couple months we'll quietly put it
back up no one will say anything you'll
get tons of press people will buy
tickets to your shows that's it that's
american politics politics is pop
culture people are losing their minds
throwing bricks at each other's faces
because of dumb people like this
i mean an alternative explanation could
be that they just didn't realize that it
would have ultimately no impact on
whether or not joe who is making more
money for spotify yeah joe rogan yeah
and in this full group that nobody's
heard of and
they're really famous they were they are
but i mean anymore how much money are
they making off of streams i mean
anywhere close to joe rogan that's
that's right that's the right point from
the demographics that are actually
watching and listening to spotify they
realized
i didn't care about their over-inflated
egos
they came crawling back and then
saying that they're going to like give
their proceeds to charity for 2019
disinformation to me that that seems
like a very soft landing for them to
return to say well we're not doing this
for ourselves we're just doing this for
everybody else i don't know why they
left to begin with neil young was the
thorn and he probably called stills
nation and um
crosby and was like dudes we got to stop
something something my politics and
they're like well neil knows what he's
talking about all right neil we got your
back and then they left and they're like
what are we doing here this is
ridiculous
i mean
any anybody who left the band anyway
anybody who knows anything about crosby
stills nash and young's they've always
been ardent authoritarian supporting the
machine in the government this is par
for the course for who they represent
their music their song four dead in ohio
about the kent state shootings in
support of it was all about supporting
the shooting
yeah
i mean they're about the most
anti-authoritarian band in the seven no
but one of them one of the comments on
this article was like about the fact
that they're baby boomers and baby
boomers are all about having the
appearance of being like freedom
fighting underdogs but they're actually
like totally
pro system
i wonder if it's like when you're
younger you just give the middle finger
to the previous generation and then when
you're older you're like give it
i don't think he was ever like that
before didn't the baby boomers start
that i don't think so i mean there's
that joke from the simpsons we like to
reference where abe simpson is like i
used to be with it but then they changed
what it was now what it is is scary you
know you know that and then he's like
it'll happen to you too
radio radicalized the youth of the time
and then tv it was the tv generation
fine was like look at what we are we
can't have men beating women that's not
normal like we got to fix something
about society because in the tv shows
that he's smacking and smacking they're
like wow
what have we become um so they were kind
of the first generation that was i like
sean connery's
i like
and he talks about backhanding women
there's videos of in defense of
backhanding you know it's crazy it's
funny does he do that yeah there's a
video of him like talking about why it's
quality and what's the value of it and
all that
really yeah it was well after it was
like decided on him
these guys just because of tv and mass
media this is like the mass media
generation these wasn't there like some
singer who beat his kids or the sack of
oranges
oh my god i don't know why a sack of
oranges because the the it hurts you but
the damage is to the flesh of the orange
so it doesn't show marks or something
like that oh my gosh yeah that's pretty
brutal dude i think like the silence is
like the silent generation or the lost
generation the world war ii generation
they were brutal were they the greatest
generation
i think when we started naming greater
generations that was like when the
mistakes started happening
i mean was it the lost generation is
that the last one like the the first one
we haven't recorded or something that's
like the late 1800s 1800s yeah the
silent generation no that was silent
afterwards yeah and then the greatest
generation but there's like it's like
it's like there's like overlap because
you know so it's hard to define
different generations because there's
there's always going to be some some
overlap between them because people have
kids all the time yeah so it's not like
it's not like every seven years everyone
goes into a chamber to have children and
there are
various like social events that will
that will define a generation that they
go through certain experiences that you
know when you when you're towards the
beginning or towards the end of that
generation you're gonna have some blend
with the other
lifetime experiences as well like you
know like like millennials have gone
through 9 11 and the great recession and
covid but you know generation
z or what what have you hasn't gone
through some of those earlier things
yeah so but there's going to be some
blend between the two where the two
intersect i wonder how it's going to
affect gen z
um obviously the older generation had
uh depending on which generation you had
vietnam and things like that in the
draft the boomers and then with the
millennials you had 911 and so you know
i don't i don't know how old you are you
do you're a woman so do you mention your
age sometimes it depends on you know i
have a form 34. i can say that oh okay
yeah so sometimes you know that what i
always say is i think i'm 34. yeah you
just ask a woman are you old enough to
where if i ask your age you'll be
offended and then you get a general idea
uh but we so we we had we all
experienced 911 but you didn't
marry no i i was a year old right right
holy cow yeah so
you didn't i wonder how that's going to
uh impact your view of the world
relative to everyone else because you're
kind of like a nihilistic
oh i don't think i'm a nihilist because
i'm catholic so sure that's right i
don't think i represent other people in
my generation either
um
for that very reason it's like is gen z
going to be more based or more woke
you know what i mean
so far like i would like to say more
based but really
the the reality is we're just more
polarized
yeah like more extreme on both ends
yeah so when the millennials are in
charge and then you're going to have gen
z gen alpha and then what comes after
alpha
alpha i don't even want it i think that
i didn't
is like the tablet babies during covid
who didn't see a human face oh man oh no
alpha and they can't read like these
kids that they can't talk
yeah they screwed yup
yeah you guys ever see a story about the
like these scientists found a young girl
that was like raised by wolves or
something
yeah and she couldn't learn english
right because her brain had had moved on
to a certain level of development where
you need you need to have society in
order for your brain those neurons to
connect and when and if your your your
brain develops beyond that point before
they connect you can't develop the
ability to
to use language yeah she could say like
grunts she could be like eat
food wow yeah i think water
that that girl she was um
she was held captive by her father until
she was like found it was that what it
was right
she eventually was able to use language
but she never
was was ever like
you know but it's like a level
protection yeah like she was never able
to be independent at all like think
about this way too there are people who
are extremely brilliant but when they
like they don't speak english
when they learn english they can't
use english the same way a proficient
english speaker would because their
brains have already like hardened right
so that's why you'll you'll see people
who are like in their 50s learn english
you can speak to them you can
communicate but for some reason they
won't say like the or or or you know an
or in like
i think it depends on how many languages
they've learned before that though
for sure i'm just saying that they're
very intelligent people who in their
native tongue could explain to you
theories of the universe but in english
you know say like me like eat pizza
fun and you're like i got the idea
say it in your you know first language
and you're going to be like the
beautiful thing about pizza is when you
get the cheese and the sauce and it's
all melty and delicious but they just
don't speak properly you know what i
mean salvador dali is a good example of
that he was like the first artist of the
tv generation of like the mass media as
we know it radio tv and he was spanish
you know i think it's spanish as his
native language barely spoke english
very rough and you could tell he's like
brilliantly talking about the fibonacci
sequence in his art if you've ever seen
dolly's artist's most surrealist amazing
stuff but when he speaks english it's
like you can barely understand what he's
saying and people just sit there and
kind of like get bored which is
unfortunate because he was such a genius
yeah and people it's funny uh oftentimes
americans assume someone's dumb
they're unintelligent because they're
not that good at speaking english
americans are some of the most like
gracious about that because so many
people have immigrated here i think it
depends though i i don't know i've seen
both sides of that
yeah like try to speak french and in
france
they're going to be mean to you when i
went to spain they were mean to me and i
can actually speak like baby
kindergarten level spanish yeah and they
would like man i was surprised i think
in america we at least appreciate that
someone is trying yeah i think it also
it also depends on the size of the
country too and the the level of of
spread of that language across the world
if it's a smaller country with a smaller
language or a language that's spoken by
fewer people they definitely will
appreciate the effort i think there's a
through line with crosby stills nation
young with this because people from that
generation their brains have formed and
now with this new information of the age
it's like yeah they knew that vietnam
was screwed they knew that there was
maybe false flags they they knew but
they didn't quite understand the the
liberal economic order um whatever you
want to call it this this world order
thing that had been established they
didn't understand there was they
definitely there was like a
multinational corporate
attempt at a takeover of the planet it
didn't they just thought like
righteousness is good the american
government's bad let's let's work it out
i don't understand then why do why do
boomers trust authoritarian
regimes like so easily like why do they
trust authorities so automatically
uh they got a lot of value from the
american dream i put in quotes they
really
sucked off the teat of the american just
mass printing of money from 1950 to 1990
they they became so wealthy and safe and
the worst thing is they think they
earned all of it yeah right like it was
their hard work and when they called
millennials entitled
positive living we were a colonizer
they are entitled but the boomers are
like just as entitled if not boomers are
uh um
boomers
did a lot of really good things but i
feel like all generations have their
good side and their bad side and it's
increasingly getting polarized so
they're they're the boomers who are the
lazy layabouts
snow plow parents who raised really
awful children and then there's the
boomers who made things like star trek
the next generation and you know pursued
civil liberties and and to this day we
still have people
you know that are that are boomers that
are doing well
it's just that
you know i think when we complain
we focus on the bad and ignore the fact
that we did get some really awesome
stuff i would not be here today if there
were not good boomers who did something
right
and the people listening to the show and
you know like everyone else's parents
it's just like
we are focused on the bad so they're
good millennials too like obviously
we're millennials
and you know we're doing all right i
think so and then there are bad
millennials who are screaming that like
their rent should be free
so but like what portion
are each of those sizes i don't know i
wonder you need data on that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there